Here is an oldie, but a goodie
for finishing the edges of your knitting.
It's not only pretty,
it can also help tame the curl of plain
stockinette knitting. Once you understand
it and get a feeling for how it's worked,
there are lots of variations
to this trim that you can employ.
Working from right to left with the purl
side of your knitting facing,
use a three prong tool and hang the edge
of the knitting on three needles.
Set your carriage for plain knitting
at a tension slightly tighter
than your garment tension.
Knit four to six rows.
You'll want to experiment
with the tension for yourself.
Moving along to the left,
pick up the edge again with the three
prong tool and hang the edge
on those same three needles.
Knit the same number of rows.
Keep picking up the edge stitches and hang
them on those same three needles
and knit the same number of rows.
Continue in this manner
until you reach a corner.
At the corner, knit an extra two rows
and then continue picking
up the edge of the knitting.
In this example, we knit four rows between
pickups and the texture isn't as defined.
Experiment with your yarn.
You can also fluff up the trim
by picking up in this stitch,
again.
Pick up the edge,
hang it on three needles,
knit four to six rows, pick up the edge,
hang it on the same needles,
knit four to six rows,
and continue all the way around the edge
of your garment
and you'll have a beautiful, worm trim.